chez un ami charlie bonsoir c'est leur
dernière j'ai le caj t de la culture au
sommaire ce soir musique à la une avec
la sortie de i'm here to nothing le
nouveau cd de craig amstrong une autre
coup de projo sur la sortie en salle de
la vengeance de monte cristo
l'adaptation signée kevin reynolds du
roman de dumas ensuite l'autre coup de
zoom sur son front le nouveau spectacle
des épis noirs au théâtre de la gaîté
montparnasse et enfin notre portrait du
cinéaste brésilien josé mojica marines
sans oublier mon interview portrait
aujourd'hui brigitte fontaine à
l'occasion de son concert au bataclan et
enfin notre deuxième invité du jour
jacques collin ex rédacteur en chef de
voici auteur de voilà chez ramsay les
bonsoir à tous cela alors qu'elisabeth
comment ça marche qui a dit de dashiell
hammett il était un écrivain aussi bon
que balzac non c'est très curieux
dashiell hammett lui lui-même qui le
nomme andré gide oui bizarre encore et j
regardez c'est très curieux arno breker
regard des sculptures d'art
mobile est survenu
dashiell hammett dont la correspondance
sur 40 ans et nord sort chez allia avec
pour titre la mort c'est pour les poires
qui était le nom de son dernier roman
qui n'a jamais terminé dette et sponsors
aux partis qui a arrêté d'écrire à 49 kg
chaque wii qui n'a jamais pu finir un
roman donc roman inachevé kkm écrit le
faucon de malte a été ensuite traduit
par faucon maltais la clé de verre et
moisson rouge et c'est passionnant parce
qu'on apprend des tas truc notamment
c'est une poire lui puisqu'il est mort
ça a été une poire il est mort pauvre
vieille demeure aux yeux quand même il
est mort en 61 66 ans oui alcool
alcoolique tuberculeux des emphysème des
ulcères et il avait
il a été très engagé il a même fait de
la taule il était complètement anti
maccarthyste il a payé il a refusé de
dénoncer ses camarades il a fait
plusieurs mois de prison et il ya des
lettres sur toute la période il a
démarré il était enquêteurs ce type a
démarré à la pinkerton à san francisco
et d'enquêteurs il est devenu auteur de
romans policiers c'est une espèce de vie
bon ça se picore je vous racontais deux
trois trucs pas tout lire c'est énorme
ça c'est formidable quel est il avait 22
mai 13e
séducteur prodigalité deuxième à la part
je suis fascinée
mon défi je voudrais vous parler de vous
ah enfin quelqu'un qui est accusé
c'est quoi le père de victor hugo un
sens et qu'ils croient que je ne suis
pas toi vous avez vous parlé de vous il
ya un atlas des français qui vient de
paraître très très bien fichu aux
éditions autrement qui a qui vous
apprendre tout ce que vous voulez savoir
sur vous
français bien sûr je pensais pas que
c'est à thierry ardisson vous intéresser
j'ai passé de prétention cela dit ce
serait pas inintéressant sur vous non
voilà des tas de choses à la fois
sérieuse et puis anecdotique très
intéressante
c'est de la sociologie vous avez 20
minutes finit donc prenez votre temps
je m'en contente voilà aujourd'hui la
production a décidé de donner vos 20
minutes et donc a pas de souci frédéric
vous vous avez beaucoup moins de temps
oui je sais même temps vous avez
interviewé hier virginie dépendent les
justes a ajouté deux trois mots sur teen
spirit qui paraît chez grasset et qui
est un livre très surprenant comme vous
l'avez dit hier c'est un c'est un livre
très moral voire familiale de la part de
l'auteur de baise moi c'est assez
étonnant et je voulais essayer de
comprendre parce qu'il ya des des
raisons générationnel qui conduisent à
ça et et littéraire également donc je
crois que voilà virginie despentes a
voulu faire la preuve qu'elle était un
écrivain tout tout court est pas un
écrivain trash avec une très belle
couverture
alors un portrait de joux
alors monsieur carmouze abord comme vous
voulez dire on va parler de ce livre que
voici que voilà
qui nous donc nous entraîne dans les
coulisses de ce journal people un peu
assez mal vu par son ancien rédacteur et
jacques collin et puis on évoquera le
fbi que voilà qui s'appelle coma vous
avez toujours rêvé veut dire il quitte
en effet un livre roman dans nos frais
les cas parler ici qui condamne beaucoup
la presse people a beaucoup jusqu'à
jusqu'à enlever les rédacteurs en chef
de journaux comme celui là pour les
faire parler et ce qu'on fait c'est tout
à fait on commence par la sortie de i'm
here to nothing le nouveau cd solo de
craig amstrong il n'aura fallu que deux
albums et deux bo pour que sa pop
populaires soient prises et de ses pairs
et primée à deux reprises par hollywood
et savent sans doute n'a pas fait la
sourde oreille et magnéto
craig amstrong déteste vraiment les
caméras et pourtant elle aime la musique
de ce talentueux compositeur de bo de
films consacrés par les golden globes
pour moulin rouge aujourd'hui l'ex élève
de la royal academy de musique de
londres sort enfin son deuxième opus
solo avec sa fusion toujours unique de
musique classique symphonique et
d'électro minimaliste
du
[Musique]
futur
mais cette vie sonore bercy de violon et
surtout avec la sable éclectique
[Musique]
mise
en scène sa mort
[Musique]
d'ailleurs pour faire découvrir son
nouvel opus dans une couleur musicale
plus classique craig amstrong se
produira le 15 septembre prochain au
théâtre des champs elysées avec 40
violeau
fin de saison
[Musique]
mais aujourd'hui entre composé une
musique de film ou un album verrou son
coeur balance
narbonne
[Musique]
justin
bieber
a décidé de dealer
merci christophe son dos voilà ce
qu serait bien de lire in spirit
virginie despentes en écoutant cette
musique il a l'art de l'ancien
m'embêterait alors vous avez cette
couverture est extrêmement branché et
puis ensuite si vous enlevez vous avez
la couverture que n'a pas eue xavier
couture c'est la couverture réservé aux
écrivains chez grasset lynch eric teen
spirit qui est
quelqu'un ici connaît un petit peu d'où
ça vient teen spirit salaire de courtes
cobain
smells like teen spirit bien sûr voilà
et donc rivaux américains et c'est un
hommage à kurt kobain et le livre est
dédié à sextoys comme vous lui avez dit
hier en fait vous l'avez tous d'hier
donc j'ai pas grand chose à ajouter
c'est vous qui m'avez parlé le premier
je vous rends voilà le rend à césar ce
qui est à césar j'ai envie quand même
deux
d'essayer d'analyser pourquoi dans son
itinéraire cette jeune femme trash
extrêmement porno qui avait débuté avec
un livre qui raconte l histoire de
nadine et manu baise moi qui
effectivement commencé par se faire
violer et puis largué tout pour partir
un peu comme thelma et louise
violet à leur tour des hommes et les le
trucider
ensuite elle est passée à un roman sur
les peep show les chiennes savantes donc
c'était aussi encore une fois quelque
chose de très sexuel le très radical
dans l'expression et puis ensuite le fil
et et puis les jolies choses et jolies
choses étaient déjà plus social que
sexuel même s'il y avait des scènes de
cul c'était quand même un roman sur deux
soeurs un roman qui peignait un peu le
milieu de la chanson d'avariés tosh et
tout ça est la célébrité qui
réfléchissaient sur un peu sur la
société et je pense qu'en réalité
virginie despentes ce houellebecq is
c'est à dire que maintenant avec teen
spirit qui raconte comment un paumé
trentenaire un peu agoraphobe qui est
chez lui à demandé à fumer des pétards
toute la journée en gardant à britney
spears à la télé comment ce bruno donc
va découvrir la vie les responsabilités
d'adultes en apprenant qu'il est papa et
il est père d'une fille de 13 ans et le
savais pas il avait pu les 13 ans
auparavant avec une petit bourge alice
martin qui elle aussi est très beau mais
finalement à sa façon je ne veux pas tu
en voilà et et donc il a cette fille
s'appelle nancy qui d'ailleurs la ville
natale de virginie despentes et puis ça
va l'obliger à bac c'était la réalité à
sortir de chez lui c'est marrant parce
que vous avez parlé récemment fait
penser que les enfants d'abord c'est
décidé
c'est un sujet dans les milieux cissé en
bretagne moi c'est dans un milieu oui
rural va mon oral le restic champêtre et
c'est aussi un peu le sujet de la
famille tanenbaum il y avait le retour
du père un père un peu clown ligne et
tout kiki bordel
voilà donc on se dit peut-être que c'est
après avoir dit famille jouait il ya un
siècle c'était andré gide maintenant
maintenant c'est famille je vous aime ou
en tout cas retrouvons nos repères après
avoir tout foutu en l'air et en mai 68
et c'est là où ça rejoint beaucoup lb
mais ça rejoint aussi anna gavalda je
trouve là c'est plutôt dans la forme
c'est à dire que c'est un petit roman
court avec des personnages qui se
rencontrent dans je l'aimais c'est aussi
l'histoire finalement après une rupture
là où il ya une rupture au début c'est
aussi l'histoire de gens qui découvrent
la parole qu'ils se parlaient pas puis
il se met à se parler à se confier à se
lâcher et
et à devenir humain et donc je trouve
qu'il ya un phénomène dans l'air du
temps 2 peut-être c'est pas une réaction
mais en tout cas c'est quelque chose
d'un peu conservateur quoi un type le
moral et et virginie despentes a
toujours dit qu'elle était moraliste a
toujours dit depuis le début même dans
baise moi même dans son film que tout le
monde qualifiait compris le nouvel obs
de facho ou de prêts geoffrey réservés
en réalité il faut une fois pu être
expliqué que ce qu'on montre à l'écran
ou dans un livre n'est pas forcément
ceux qu'on aime parfois on peut décrire
des choses
moche pour les désapprouver l'auteur
n'est pas forcément dans tous les
personnages etc etc ça fait du bien de
le rappeler parfois voile annoncé tous
sinon moi ça m'a aussi fait penser à
l'attrape-coeur de salinger le coup
puisque c'est l'histoire d'une
adolescente et qui refuse de vieillir et
ça c'est un sujet éternel mais là avec
la forme qui est celle de dépenses c'est
à dire du rythme du rythme de l'énergie
et des phrases courtes et je crois que
pour conclure en fait je répétais ce que
j'ai dit sur besson mais si tout le
monde pouvait le faire et bien ça se
saurait parce que assez peu de gens
finalement elle a été beaucoup beaucoup
imité
virginie despentes mais assez pesant un
peu de gens ont réussi à écrire comme ça
voilà donc je le conseille c'est in
spirit teen spirit de kurt kobain g
grâce où il réitère donc sa fille petit
éditeur de xavier pictures et
d'elisabeth quin
sur la sortie en salle de la vengeance
de monte cristo est l'adaptation signée
kevin reynolds sûrs au monde dumas dans
laquelle edmond n'est plus dantesques
mais grotesque frédérick dionne et à les
démonter que rester au magnéto
malgré les apparences certains films de
série b américain en disent long sur la
fabrication des films outre atlantique
c'est le cas de la vengeance de monte
cristo blockbuster à costumer gros
mammouth fabriqués pour le public
international après avoir été trahis et
emprisonné à edmond dantès est un héros
qui rebondit sur tous les ressorts comme
le cinéma populaire mais c'est surtout
alexandre dumas son auteur qui plaît
pente au studio américain
[Musique]
et avec la grève en 2001 des scénaristes
à hollywood dumas a donné des idées aux
producteurs démunis
mais à la trappe les adaptations
européenne trop intello pour monte
cristo les studios utilisent les
ficelles les plus énormes
le film doit garantir des scènes
d'action pure alterné des seuils
psychologiques de base et à montage
rapide tout est formaté pour le public
américain réputé pour être jeune et diss
track
à
[Musique]
hinault
mais ce qui est frappant c'est ce besoin
de morale et de bonnes pensées
obligatoire qui ont toutes les
adaptations américaine ici le
manichéisme frappe fort et si
montecristo se vengea c'est seulement
après 1h10 de films d'ici là on aura vu
ses 13 années d'emprisonnement au
château d'if comme s'il avait fallu
justifier moralement sa soif de revanche
break c'est donc nouveau cet américain
monte cristo est très gentil un
sympathique héros animé de pulsions
divine et pour terminer la recette il
est indispensable c'est le happy
merci frédéric viale
alors ce qu'on regrette en fait dans la
rio ainsi que le type ne soit pas en
train de flageller dagmar
diabète vous que je sais même pas ce que
ça vous renseigner je préfère parler de
la mort c'est pour les points
lâchés à la m ce compromis effectivement
vous aviez raison entre james dean et
darryl zanuck grands producteurs qu'on
surnommait le renard argenté il me
semble qu'il avait le poil blanc
dashiell hammett j'en sais rien c'est du
noir et blanc bon voilà il ya une sortie
de bouquins assez intéressante la
correspondance de cet homme que vous
connaissez tous puisque vous avez tous
vu le faucon maltais me la clé de verre
s'est pendu chez allia avec deux ailes
voilà la mort c'est pour les poids alors
saviez vous qu'il était détective
dashiell hammett viège shipping carte
anastasie regarde moi j'ai regardé les
drafts gauche s'allumant il était
détective sceptiques curtoni gagnait pas
beaucoup d'argent et il décrivait
frénétiquement des nouvelles qui
l'envoyaient à des pulp et le pulp le
plus célèbre entre tous était black mask
faudra donc commencer nouvelliste et
puis il ya une espèce de coup de génie
en 31 il a écrit et en 30 le faucon de
malte qui est devenu le faucon maltais
et qui est devenu évidemment le film de
john huston avec un très beau gars et
qui a été à la raymond chandler qui
était quand même pas la moitié d'une
ouïe lui a rendu un hommage
plus libre en dix ans donc de dashiell
hammett il a tiré le meurtre du
presbytère pour le rendre aux véritables
spécialistes c'est à dire les priver les
gommes shoes les enquêteurs les
enquêteurs or le commissariat également
bon une vie absolument invraisemblable
40 ans de vie donc à picorer parce qu'on
peut pas nous enfin c'est pas
suffisamment non plus à moins d'être
passionné par la vie d'hollywood des
studios les rapports entre les
scénaristes les romanciers les studios
c'est trop long c'est trop énorme c'est
trop riches il faut picorer mais une vie
incroyable le type était d'abord un
menteur impénitent il était marié avec
une femme qui s'appelait joséphine qu'il
adorait il a une maîtresse pendant 30
ans et puis dos des enfants à droite à
gauche y dépenser tout l'argent qui
gagnait
alors crise en plein milieu dont il y
avait 40 ans il peut plus écrire
commence à écrire un roman la mort donc
c'est pour les poires des sports soccer
peut plus finir et il est quand même
marrant 61 c'est à dire que pendant 20
ans ce type a essayé désespérément
décrire c'était fini s'était tarie
peut-être parce qu'il avait une activité
de citoyens qui a pris le pas sur son
activité de scénaristes et surtout de
romancier il est devenu très engagé
contre le maccarthysme dans les années
50 il a refusé de dénoncer des camarades
à lui scénariste romancier il a fait de
la prison
ecrouves mais j'ai même le numéro
d'écrou alors on apprend des trucs
inutiles mais bon intéressant numéro 84
16 h lente dans le kentucky il ya des
lettres écrites en prison assez
touchante parce que quoi qu'il arrive il
conservait une dignité une sorte de
dérision alors je vais juste dire deux
choses d'abord ce que disait sa fille
c'est sa fille qui a décidé de la de la
publication des lettres évidemment il
n'était pas question d publié de son
vivant et sa fille dit la chose suivante
la plupart de mes amis boivent plus que
de raison écrivait scott fitzgerald plus
ils sont en phase avec leur époque plus
ils boivent concluait scott fitzgerald
et bien papa devait être rudement en
phase avec son époque j'aime bien
jugement parce qu'on sent tout le monde
il ya derrière la fille qui a quand même
souffert de l'alcoolisme génial mais
alcoolisme quand même de son frère et
voilà ce que disait dashiell hammett de
de son apport qui a été fondamental la
révolution du roman noir c'est lui c'est
à dire qu'avant on décrivait juste une
situation il y avait un suspense qui a
tué machin ou qui a volé sa il a
introduit la psychologie l'étude du
comportement de la société de la faune
qui était la faune de cette chandeleur
est lui-même mais peut-être encore à
mettre plus dans le sens où à mettre en
tout cas amener quelque chose qui était
très cinématographiques blic d'ailleurs
les dialogues de l'amérique réseau de
chaleur le grand saut
mais il y avait un truc dans les romans
de la m c'était des dialogues
incroyablement cinématographique très
lapidaire très sec très brillant on
pouvait adapter directement donc voilà
ce qu'il disait sur sa démarche
d'écrivain je souhaite c'était très tôt
c'était en 28 je souhaite appliquer ou
roman policier le style du monologue
intérieur il avait lu la littérature
européenne invraisemblablement aménagé
certes le lecteur suivant pas à pas le
détective qui l'associerait à tout ce
qu'il découvre au fur et à mesure on est
dans le mental
l'informant de ces conclusions les sons
la solution s'imposait à tous deux en
même temps voilà et il dit aussi je suis
l'une des rares personnes moyennement
cultiver j'aime sa modestie qui prennent
le roman policier au sérieux un jour un
type en fera de la littérature je suis
assez égocentrique pour espérer avoir
mes chances même s'il me reste à faire
mes preuves les a fait quoi voilà donc
chez allia tout une correspondance la
dernière lettre juste avant qu'il meure
c'est un cri d'amour abbey lee ann
hellman qui était une dramaturge qu'il a
aimés pendant 30 ans était sa maîtresse
ce magnifique y remercie i10 et fax
giving aujourd'hui il meurt quelques
jours après je remercie dieu c'est un
mystère pourquoi ai-je eu cette femme
que je ne méritais pas le type était
modeste compliqué tourmenté est génial
et un film sur l'histoire d'un film de
wenders qui s'appelait m avec frédéric
forest dans le rôle alors wenders
carrément délire dit c'est le plus grand
écrivain américain du siècle avec folder
et hemingway peut-être pas mais grand
auteur des romans noirs merci elizabeth
et la prochaine fois vous nous parlez de
dagmar hagelin
l'enquêté démarre à
damas
je verrai
dagmara
[Musique]
aujourd'hui brigitte fontaine à
l'occasion de son
cher ami cher et demi rue on se retrouve
son interview portrait aujourd'hui
brigitte fontaine à l'occasion de son
concert au bataclan bonsoir donc aussi
mignon comment ça va alors on dit on
parle il se la pète beaucoup et pas du
tout moi aussi derrière on dit en
parlant de vos brigitte fontaine que
vous êtes une icône mais finalement ça
vous plaît pas beaucoup je ne sais pas
unique voilà j'ai dit que je suis une
unique
c'est vrai que vous êtes en plus pas
immobile sur scène donc qui cote ont dit
vous êtes une chanteuse culte ça vous
ennuie aussi parce que vous trouvez ça
trop élitaire et vous préféreriez
finalement séduire le grand public
bah c'est ce qui est en train de se
produire oui oui c'est ce qui est en
train de saint paul ont dit vous êtes
folle vous êtes loin d'être folle
je suis simplement avec différentes moi
c'est tout outre la visite à la folie
c'est dangereux c'est terrible et une
nouvelle pouvoir ouais les faits graves
est terrible voilà enfin bon s'il
fallait dire que c'est falaq est alors
je suis simplement un peu différente des
autres voilà vous voyez l'arrêt dans les
rangs mais beaux
jours à la plata
est bien rouge et noir comme ça c'est
beau à l'image suis sûr noir océan noir
et oui on doit être pauvre doit être
assez bien tous deux alors votre look
surprend certains il fait même peur josé
artur j'aurais jamais cru
sicile avec votre look lui faisait peur
nombre n ont rien n'est fait par devant
et lui et
il peut pas il se plante jamais
magnifique il est parfait alors donc on
va faire un petit peu de promotion
brigitte fontaine vous êtes ici pour la
sortie de votre nouveau single le
troisième single extrait de votre nouvel
album qui s'appelle kékéland 1 et ça
s'intitule pipo et le ce gros tubes du
disque 1 c'est l'amour c'est du pipeau
seront pour les gogos ça c'est
l'amour c'est du pipeau c'est bon pour
les gogos bah voilà rien à dire c'est
définitif dans est en tournée jusqu'en
octobre
en france et le 16 mai mesdames
messieurs le 16 mai au bataclan walid
fontaine oui je remets ça car le corps
rex était hyper complet en un raté genre
3000 personnes
dommage mais le bataillon c'était aussi
un oui moi j'aime beaucoup parce que les
gens aiment beaucoup mais bon pour moi
parce que c'est
on est debout tout le monde est là sa
musique ils ont tous des amarres au fond
par les pico lauréats bien on danse et
on écoute
le fond parfait donc c'est le 16 mai
mesdames messieurs notez le bien sûr vos
petits agents de ben voilà alors kike
landes gros succès un déjà plus de cent
mille exemplaires vendus vous êtes en
jeu disque d'or donc comme on dit dans
le métier alors vous expliquer qu est ce
qu un kéké un kéké c'est un être
adorable minou
fou
allumé
gentillesse redresser probablement sur
la tête ou les filles aussi
un peu de bol ce oui qu'est-ce que vous
êtes des exemples de keke de gens dont
vous pourriez dire ce sont de vrais
geeks et
m'ont vu lancer rist est un vrai que
matthieu chedid aussi matthieu chedid m
darne attendrait quelques authentiques 1
à la télé ya pas trop de casse
alors vous trouvez toujours avec areski
belkacem est oui sur ce disque est là à
oui c'est le meilleur
voilà et vous avez travaillez beaucoup
avec qui je leur en parler on va voir la
place que ces deux hommes ont tenu dans
votre vie on va parler un petit peu de
votre vie on va raconter un petit peu
votre vie vous avez connu non sinon le
présent si tout ce que vous deviez très
intéressant la vie c'est n'importe quoi
ah non mais bien c'est le passé crasseux
non pas du tout justement que ces débats
vous êtes né à morlaix dans le nord delà
de la bretagne
oui oui c'est beau et vous êtes une
visière corsaires du parti faisait 14
ans et quand vous êtes revenu à mort les
avant d'enregistrer kékéland donc d'être
revenu à morlaix ils avaient tous vos
amoureux qui vous et même les toits
qu'il attendait à la gare c'est pas beau
ça c'est hyper romantique arrêté
oui oui et alors vous avez écrit
kékéland d'air dans un petit hôtel en
bretagne
finalement ses fidèles à vos racines
monde a frais dans vos parents étaient
instituteurs
ancré dans la laïcité dans l'anti
cléricalisme et c'est votre grand mère
c'est incroyable c'est votre grand mère
que tu es la retraite elle faisait 2 km
de plus sur les chez l'épicier parce que
l'épicier qui était à côté de chez elle
avait mis ses gosses et les curés oui et
mon arrière grand père était également
un sister lake vous êtes vraiment une
enfant de l'aïe alors première passion
c'était le théâtre donc commencé très
jeune à lire des pièces et à monter des
troupes d'amateurs et vous avez été
repérés temps de quoi vous avez vraiment
déjà très jeune quelque chose à l'âge de
12 ans vous êtes repéré par un directeur
de troupe leçons dramatiques de l'ouest
j'adorerais petite merveille ouais ça
s'est pas fait
à mes parents mes parents oui de
de m'avoir quand j'aurai 16 ans non
seulement ils ont refusé mais une
marianne c'est terrible ça vous aurait
donné confiance en son nom ça m'aurait
permis d'éviter de laisser un homme
aurait permis de faire la vie dont je
n'osais même pas rêver et ça m'aurait
évité plein plein de galère à paris
aurait
en tous les cas dès cette époque que
vous saviez que vous écririez que vous
feriez du théâtre savait pas encore à
l'époque que vous chanteur vit
exactement vous saviez déjà vous êtes
une artiste exactement mais je vous
confie
la chose qui m'a scandalisé la première
fois que je suis allé à l'école ouais
c'est qu'on n'avait pas le droit de
chanter parce que moi j'arrivais tout à
fait normalement émergentes et et
maintenant on fait pas un voilà bon sur
cas d'école alors une adolescence à ces
révoltés on peut dire rebel rebel envers
vos parents vers la société alors vous
passiez d après midi je vois très bien -
en train de lire des livres dostoïevski
avec les volets fermés les bougies
allumées comme sociale
c'est vrai c'est vrai on vous voit très
bien à l'époque
alors votre premier choc musical c'est
gainsbourg et vous dites que c'est le
plus grand c'est vraiment j'ai quelque
chose à qui vous a marqué les buts
ivement un oui franc et l'euro début des
années 60 bac en poche vous débarquez à
paris bien décidé à monter sur scène et
en fait ce qui s'est passé que j'ai fait
est-ce que c'est oui mais ce qui s'est
passé c'est qu'à l'époque vous aviez un
mec au des bulles celui qui avec un mec
un mètre 98 15 ans de plus que vous oui
un code peut dire la vérité un bon il
avait une emprise sur voûté
l'emprise c'est ça hein ça il est dit
jaloux je m'en fous des partenaires
masculins
et ce connard me demandent non exige que
je renonce à mon doute meti que dit que
ça mais c'est une [ __ ] un emploi et
moi comme une [ __ ] aussi jeu
j'obtempère
mais oui c'est là que je commence h mais
voilà par ruse c'est-à-dire sournoise
immense et féminine vous dit tu veux pas
que je fasse deux là s'aiment c'est pas
grave vous êtes passé comme ça un peu à
part russe pour rester dans le monde du
spectacle oui dans le monde du spectacle
et puis avoir le quota les jo et surtout
qui se passe une petite cérémonie tous
les soirs si ça m'intrigue voilà alors
finalement donc
vous commencez vous commencé à chanter
vous avez dans des boîtes à la rive
gauche et beuglant
la fin
des mecquois la rose rouge rude règne
avec moi comme ça
mais si tout ce qu'ils avaient et là il
gèle un soir vous rencontrent là vous
vous le rencontrez d'entrée l'autre et
vient me voir là où je chantais oui et
il me propose de
que nous fassions une pièce on s'en va
là avec leur fils alors là c'est
pourquoi vous avez encore perdu mais
avec la legrand là d'un mètre 98 g père
qui chasse avec un flingue j'étais
terrorisée
moi que je suis là parce que moi je suis
un exégète de votre vie ouais et alors
donc vous vous continuez donc le théâtre
évidemment puisque l'autre était plus là
et avec higelin et rufus oui rires
fusent sur le savoir qu'ils étaient
internes dans les hôpitaux de rouen
exactement un tous les trois vous
écrivez vous monter une pièce qui est un
énorme succès oui ma marche énorme
énorme succès parce que tout commence là
en fait et vous laisser piéger la jouer
ensuite au théâtre des champs elysées
oui et vous partir en tournée pendant un
an françois s'éteindrait et même en
autriche
belgique
gros succès 1 ils auront 65 jacques tène
et il en faut dire qu'il jacques canetti
de santis jacques canetti découvreur de
brel de brassens de tabac à tout le
monde créateur des trois baudets et
s'intéresse à vous ça c'était avant
ouais c'était avant oui mais c'est
intéressant quand même une petite erreur
c'était avant avant quoi avant mangez
pas d'accord avant maman j'ai peur il
vous fait quoi je connais mieux me fait
enregistrer et passant là dessus parce
que le disque est acheté à la poubelle
je le dis fermement à quiconque aurait
envie d'acheter ces 10,1 et sais pas
comment il s'appelle donc
douze chansons d'avant le des juges ou
un truc comme ça les touche en son temps
d'une chanson d'appréhender le jeu
serait selon
bref il faut jeter ça à la va quant à
elle très bien ce qu'ils ont et
autrement ne l'achetait pas faux bien
commencé d'accord mais c'est vraiment
celui qui est sorti en 68 qui s'appelle
brigitte fontaine et fun vous le
recommander ou non ça va ça va ça va à
part le titre que j'ai pas choisi ouais
oui on sent que oui on s'en fout c'est
que la barousse annonce n'est pas à le
posséder chez star
apparaît alors là vous rencontrez areski
belkacem donc été longtemps après
régiment régiment
voilà et lorsque très marrant de votre
histoire avec lui c'est qu'au départ
vous bosser avec lui pendant
pratiquement je prends comme un damné 3
en 1 voilà trois ans rien rien on était
très bons amis et ont travaillé j'avais
fait deux ou trois ans rien et
sous-vêtements coup de foudre terrific
la presse est juste
c'est au bout de trois ans comme en un
seul coup vous pouvez voir le coût du
loyer depuis trois ans oui bah je sais
pas ça tout d'un coup ça s'il met à
chauffer à jouer à chauffer argent et
puis passion pression patiente à sion et
ça dure encore et ça dure encore vous
dites c'est mon compositeur préféré en
france et je vais pas me priver parce
que c'est mon mari voilà donc vous
continuer à bosser avec lui ça se passe
très bien alors le trio higelin rezki
fontaine a beaucoup de succès alors je
vais citer trois chansons en aurez plein
qu on pourrait citer m'enfin moi je
parle de ces dossiers qui vont marquer
cet enfant que je t'avais fait
magnifique chanson lettre à monsieur le
chef de gare de latour de carol et là
c'est moi qui
allais ce qui est déjà un petit joue
avec la
jolie
et comme à la radio
comme à la radio oui mais pas jacques
n'est pas l'âge mais voilà et puis un
jour le trio donc
fontaine gelin skis se sépare parce
qu'un jour vous en avez marre de la
place qu'il joue l'un prend sur scène il
était un peu énervant je suis parti en
plein milieu une fois du spectacle vous
êtes traverser là
j'ai pris mes bagages j'ai traversé la
seine j'ai traversé la salle et je vais
pas revenu sur une moto le parrain ah
non non non c'est cela notre cousin de
rien plus si tu vois pas ce que nous
faisons est sacrée c'est à peu près
improvisé
donc je vais tout le monde a cru que ça
faisait partie des spectacles
demain soir où les gens ont compris que
vous étiez vraiment parti kwa web est
parti au bout d'un quart d'heure donc la
boule à et après à jacques je lui ai
conseillé vraiment de faire sa une un
truc tout seul ouais et de prendre tout
le truc et surtout de faire du
rock'n'roll voilà comme je savais qu'il
aimait ça voilà ça lui a bien réussi pas
mal pas mal et alors là vous entrez de
vous entrez dans un exil volontaire
c'est à dire que vraiment vous c'est
vous qui vous quitté il ya décroché à
improviser à peu près complètement
c'est à dire moi et à risquer
web pendant un certain temps après bon
exil oui c'est à dire nous avons joué
une pièce de théâtre que j'avais écrite
areski belkacem et moi
on aimait beaucoup beaucoup on a fait
des tournées dans toute la france et à
l'étranger un peu et puis en même temps
je vois c'est que ceignac c'est ça non
non non quoi voir c'est quoi l'acteur
non non ça s'appelle quand on l'a joué
appelé acte ii et on livre édité elle
s'appelle la conciliabules
alors bon ensuite vous disparaissez un
petit peu du sud une sacrée dérive ou
bien entendu beaucoup de livres et alors
vous revenez ccc etienne daho qui vous a
permis de vous annoncer les japonais ah
oui oui les japonais qui ont absolument
voulu produire un disque qui surtout a
absolument voulu que je fasse une
tournée au japon ce qui me plaisait pas
car j'aime pas trop les avions pourquoi
parce qu'on ne peut pas fumer
taxe exceptionnelle vous mais personne à
droite je n'ai plus jamais fumé ouais
nulle part et à partir du mois de juin
je demande à tout le monde de se
révolter car partir du mois de juin
ici en france on ne peut plus fumer dans
les travaux continueront troué manvieu
on va faire ça par la région
non c'est vrai ça c'est une honte mais
oui c'est vrai ah bah disons
c'est ce qui vous a donné envie de
revenir qui vous a donné envie de donc
les japonais ont des japonais se disent
qu'en plus ils se disent cours d'une
tournée au japon ok et
il ya le nougat dans ce disque et ça a
commencé par un petit mot un petit
malheur le nougat et après moi je
continue ainsi je suis allée j'imagine
qui est pour moi une excellente maison
ou que je suis ravi et je vais trois
disques la renontre aux quatre
derniers
qui marche bien ouais c'est la
conclusion donc kékéland le morceau dont
le single c'est pipeau 1 et puis voilà
pipeau tournée en france comme je disais
et donc le 16 mai au bataclan voilà on a
fait le tour du problème l'affairé
réglée mais je vous en prie merci a
bientot egypte après les pubs place est
notre deuxième invité du jour ce soir
jacques collin ex rédacteur en chef de
voici auteur de voilà chez ramsay a plus
chers amis chers ennemis re re on se
retrouve avec jacques collin ex
rédacteur en chef de voici hauteur de
voilà chez ramsay bonsoir bonsoir donc
patrice vous nous présenter le livre ma
famille nous dira d'abord
les show with de métro des bas mais on
désespère pas de le faire enfin l'autre
jacolin ex rédacteur en chef de voici
qui publie donc voilà ce sont 63 jours
dans les coulisses de voici donc le
titre déjà chez g rap c'est
par l'éditeur et où devaient avoir
face à lui xavier couture qui écrit chez
grasset comme à un roman dont frédéric a
dit tout le bien qu'il fallait en penser
enfin qu'il en pensait lui même en tout
cas kate qui est en effet un roman où
est mise en cause la nasse qu'on appelle
la presse people puisque rédacteur en
les rédacteurs en charge la plus qu'elle
n'est pas en soi ce gala parra mais bon
un peu genre voici dont le rédacteur
d'un le rédacteur en chef d'un journal
genre voici est pris en otage par
quelqu'un qui a été pris en photo par ce
journal qui a fait la couverture de ce
journal donc ce qu'il faut dire c'est
que xavier couture qui est directeur de
l'antenne de tf1
nous a appelés ce matin pour dire qu' il
avait un empêchement de minutes en
commun ce qui est bien dommage mais ce
qui me vaut peut-être empêchera pas de
parler de lui peut-être de réorganiser
le débat quand une autre partie sera
libre
alors pour pour parler de jacques collin
dochia été rédacteur en chef en effet de
voici abalo lui le titre nous dit à peu
près tout mais c'est vrai qu'il ya en
effet les coulisses de voici et il ya un
peu plus que ça je dirais parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'ils profitent de ce
livre pour nous dire des choses qui n'a
peut-être pas pu dire dans voici parce
que la loi ne l'y autorisait pas parce
que peut-être les services juridiques du
journal auquel il a eu affaire à la fin
de sa carrière puisque on leur demandait
de faire en sorte qu'ils aient un peu
moins de procès qu'il soit fait qu'il
soit faire voici ne lui permettait pas
décrire tout ce qu'ils voulaient donc il
ya des choses un peu connais pas très
codé parce que on se rend compte de qui
de qui vise et de qui parle 1
par exemple une grande actrice alors il
peut pas le dire parce que si on disait
les noms il y aurait il y aurait
par exemple prend 100 mille francs en
liquide son iphone pour aller animer une
vente de charité au cours de laquelle la
chose elle achète pour dix ou quinze
mille fronde 20 mais tout le monde est
serré qu'il a dit quelques heures
formidable actrice que c'est lui reste
85 pour la soirée alors bon on peut se
douter il n'y a pas plus
voilà en gros tu sais pas 1 est ce que
c'est un présentateur de journal
télévisé qui fait pipi sur le canapé non
c'est pas que c'est un cadre supérieur
sur le canapé du vraiment hâte heures
oui parce que parce que il levait il
voulait la même femme est en fait je
crois qu'elle voulait pas être avec les
c'est vraiment toute
l'équipe a paru nous voici à ce qu'il
n'aurait pas pu les voler pige au pire
un peu plus hier voici les coulisses et
puis un peu plus que voici voilà il ya
aussi une autre chose c'est d'essayer de
montrer que la frontière entre voici et
la presse people traditionnel et très
très minces parce qu'en fait la presse
people traditionnelle fait à peu près la
même chose j'ai apporté ici un dossier
je nourrirais et de 6,8 à en trois
épisodes un grand hebdomadaire
du milieu de semaine sur la vie
tourmentée de stéphanie de monaco où on
nous raconte qu'elle est avec comme
monsieur qui a un cirque en suisse
ensuite on nous raconte la dame du
monsieur est très malheureuse parce
qu'elle s'est fait piquer son mec donc
elle le raconte dans paris match et
après on trouve stéphanie de nouveau
seul et c'est ça c'est pas c'est pas
dans voici et on pourrait même le
trouver dans des magazines locaux plus
respectueux
respectable que ça
assure l'ailier bon c'est à ses
habitants il ya des choses quand même
quelqu'un qui m'ont surpris the c'est
que après vous êtes référé
j'aurais pas dû réfléchir à des choses
qui vont suivre il paraît donc vous
bidaude est oui alors ça c'est pas bien
parce que c'est vrai qu'on peut se dire
ouais si beau c'est pas c'est peut-être
pas le seul membre de la presse etc mais
au moins ils disent enfin ils peuvent se
réfugier derrière tout le fait que les
gens connus après tout il est normal que
il profite de la notoriété qu'ils ont
donc il normal qu on cherche un petit
peu ce qui va gagner sur le service
public là que nous suivons oui vous
savez je pense qu'on peut le dire
aujourd'hui luis mariano chanter pour
les femmes mais le magma chauffeur bon
ça n'était pas du tout raconté à
l'époque et on lui trouvait dans la
presse des amants et voici evilard l'a
fait aussi voilà ya plein de gens qui se
servent de la dune presse
pour pouvoir asseoir ce genre de
relation et nous mêmes nous le faisons
aussi c'est à dire je ne vais pas citer
de noms mais par exemple une
présentatrice de télévision qui le
visage tuméfié et vous savez très bien
que c'est son mec qui lie qui l'a frappé
et vous dites dans voici elle a été
agressée dans un parking
pour la banque qui va ça pas pour la
banlieue pour
la nuit oui c'est pas de la vraie
banlieue qui participent à ce mensonge
alors si si si votre votre quête et
votre votre nous justifier notre
justification c'est la vérité pourquoi
vous participez vous à des mensonges là
c'est le pouvons la vérité en fait c'est
que cette dame nous rendait aussi des
services
qu'est ce qu'on peut savoir qu'est-ce
qui lé vrai qu'est ce qu'il fout c'est
comme dans la vie
si on dit on
savait pas trop si vous demandez où les
citernes ou les lecteurs vous dise on
s'en fout de savoir si c'est vrai ce
qu'on veut c'est que ce soit drôle qui
est quelque chose et qu'on nous raconte
une histoire il faut comprendre ça ça
c'est dans toutes les lettres de
lecteurs et vous pouvez les interroger
tous c'est c'est un budget national ans
c'est autre chose d'accord mais elle en
dit pas on est journaliste yapaka voici
qu'on invente témoin faisait remplir un
formulaire de carte de presse tous les
tous les ans mais on en aurait privé
j'aurais volontiers payer un peu plus
d'impôts c'est je ne revendique pas
d'avoir fait du journaliste par contre
je pense que il ya d'autres gens qui
revendiquent faire du journalisme qui
n'en font pas plus que moi mais pour
pratiquer dans ce que je veux dire par
là c'est que nous avons dit que quand
même une certaine morale après tout oui
maersk line transparence non d'abord il
ya comme une grille les gens connus il
c'est normal qu'ils soient à peu près
transparent gros c'est ça ne lave ou
deux filles et une vocation un peu
subversif de montrer l'envers des
chaudières il ya quelque chose qui est
très amusant dans une interview de
monsieur couture d'un à télé 7 jours ce
matin je sais pas si je vais le
retrouver il dit de toute façon ce qui
est très désagréable dans cette presse
c'est que voilà les femmes ont
systématiquement de la cellulite et les
hommes paraissent centenaire en fait
c'est pas des photos truquées ce que ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
dans les autres journaux les femmes
n'ont plus de cellulite et les hommes de
l'art est plus centenaire et je pense
que le rôle de voici six ans n'a en tous
cas c'est de montrer un petit peu les
gens tels qu'ils sont et d'europe ces
règles voit bruce willis avec un gros
bide qui va au supermarché avec
entraîneurs de chien c'est vrai non mais
c'est vrai oui mais ce sont la vérité de
son club sa valeur et vise à mission
adipeuses de l'homme c'est ça
votre édition la voie dans un délai
minimum pour la première fois dans voici
c'est vrai c'est un choc
c'est vrai qu'est ce qu'ils sont malins
là il d une puce trouve formidable c'est
carla bruni 1 parce que elle elle est
extrait vous devez normand valide c'est
à dire quel invité jacques collin elle a
fait elle était amie avec vous elle vous
avez un radis des raids invite à dîner
elle joue de la guitare avec lui alors
il n'y a jamais eu un mot sur carla
bruni dont voici donc
ça c'est très fort c'est ce qu'il faut
faire mais oui je pense oui
je ne répondrai pas dès demain
en général je ne parle pas de la vie
privée des gens
suivent pas sur la mienne je peux en
parler mais je ne vais pas attenter à
ses attentes et à celles de mademoiselle
bruni
qu'est ce que je voulais dire j'ai
oublié c'est la grave sinon l'homme à
dire qu'en fait ce que disait car oui
c'est qu'il faut des
fossés blair aussi quand même parce que
je sais pas si ça aurait marché avec
j'ai passé un marché avec claire chazal
précis comme les autres journaux
finalement sur bouffe avec le rédacteur
en chef directeur de rédaction d'un
traité exactement et d'ailleurs mon
erreur ça a été de me mettre à déjeuner
d'abord parce que j'ai pris du poids et
ensuite parce que effectivement
chaque fois que vous rencontrez
quelqu'un sur ces foutus après vous
gardez
ces morts il faut alors pour faire se
joignent
de connivence s'annonce ce journal il
faut le faire comme ça abbas un coin il
faut pas bouger et connaître personne
sauf à être une espèce de justiciers du
fairway ainsi on se décalait vers moi je
suis mal placé je suis salarié de voici
aller travailler avec jacques pendant
cinq ans je crois enfin je suis pas très
très bien placé pour parler du livre je
n'avais pas du tout objectif ce que l'on
constate en l'écoutant c'est qu'il a
beaucoup d'autodérision qu' il n'a pas
envie de donner des leçons de morale et
de vertu au reste de la planète que
ils prenaient pas énormément tout ça au
sérieux je crois que d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être ça va aussi
me reproche voilà c'est un peu mais un
peu le reproche qu'on pourrait lui faire
dire que c'est un livre qui est marrant
où il ya des anecdotes ou en même temps
c'est pas trop quel camp ils choisi
parce que ils critiquent beaucoup voici
ils critiquent beaucoup les dirigeants
de ce journal c'est encore plus les gens
qui te fait que voici donc et critique
aussi ceux qui critiquent bêtement il a
tendance à dire qu'il y avait des trucs
bidonné alors qu'en fait bon quand même
la plupart des trucs son vrai dans le
journal c'est à dire enfin bon c'est sûr
le bideau d'âge il faut préciser que le
pourcentage ce qui n'excuse rien le
pourcentage est peu important parce que
sinon ça marche plus le lecteur de voici
ce sur quoi ils s'appuient c'est le fait
il sait que c'est vrai et qu'il en a eu
la preuve sur lui c'est avec des trucs
bidons hills on irait
alors il explique les informateurs comme
el mathari notamment voilà il respecte
ou les comment ça se passe la remontée
de la france mais je vienne faire
arrondir leurs fins de mois on vous
donnait des informations c'est à dire
qu'il vient de vous voir directement un
peu comme les impôts ou un truc
les baiia récolte galabru il fait plein
de films pop et ses impôts y compris des
films d'autres qui ne revendique pas et
puis il y en a d'autres iphone ça dépend
de ce qu'ils doivent s'ils ont besoin
que de quinze ou vingt mille balles il
passa voici et puis ça les arrange
la formatrice alors principal que vous
appelez mathari donc vous voulez pas
donné le nom c'est pour toujours pas non
non non non tu donc j'en aurais passé
une autorisation
elle fera son outing tout seul alors le
livre s'ouvre il faut quand même dire ça
puisque vous parlez couture le livre
s'ouvre sur une scène qui est au fond le
pour aider ce qu'on veut dire le
kidnapping notre faveur d'un paparazzi
par un présentateur de journal télévisé
et son frère dans une grecque
vous raconter cette histoire est que
ferrari
un paparazzi qui suivait un présentateur
du journal télévisé alors c'est très
amusant d'abord la façon dont ça se
passe c'est à dire que enfin si vous
voulez raconter c'est à dire comment on
sait par exemple que se présentait
encore là qui sortait à l'époque avec
qui la présentatrice d'un journal
télévisé j'ai pas si on peut citer des
noms si on les genres comme vous le
savez qu'ils vont partir en vacances à
cet amusant et ben c'est très simple les
paparazzis surveille les programmes télé
et quand ils s'aperçoivent que les deux
présentateurs sont remplacés il suppose
à bonne escient d'ailleurs on le voit
qui vont partir en vacances donc après
il ya des gens qui prennent le relais
dans les deux aéroports à paris donc
c'est pas très difficile en plus et puis
il ya des il ya des espèces de vichy qui
sont installés un peu partout
et en trois coups de téléphone on sait
exactement que bruce willis arrive ou
que
mais c'est insensé j'y suis allé
raconter une anecdote personnelle un
jour j'étais dans un restaurant et
jacques martel il me dit voilà tu es
dans un restaurant avenue montaigne en
terrasse avec une petite brune j ouer
comment tu sais ça
j'étais ma femme
c'est vrai j'avais dire les personnes
qui avaient plus je me dis si c'est une
petite brune s'est probablement
béatrice voilà c'était ma femme donc la
coupole mais ça veut dire quand même que
où qu'on soit avec on a une tronche un
peu connus on explique qu'il n'est pas à
l'abri mais c'est le cas ils
s'aperçoivent qu'ils partent cependant
une île grecque et donc n'est pas brad
il est suivi l'on compte le même avion
ça s'est amusé enfin ils sont tous dans
le même avis - c est donc ça c'est un
système qui est très répandue c'est ce
qu'elles aillent là ils sont allés voir
juste les gens obligés de dire untel ou
est-ce qu'elle par les adultes ratés y
ait raison oui c'est formidable s'est
effacée habitants oui alors après les
gens qui sont suivis s'aperçoivent que
des paparazzi les suivent ils en
prennent un et ils l'ont fait dans un
dans le garage de la villa où ils sont
et casser un peu la gueule oui beaucoup
vos pas mal le pas mal donc ça ça a
donné un procès ça donne ayant un procès
c'est comme ça que s'ouvre le livre oui
un procès qui aurait pu ne pas avoir
lieu puisque pour ne pas le citer
monsieur mougeotte avait sollicité d'un
ami tropézien que je ne citerai pas mais
qui expédie réalisé dans le gobie
twinning de rencontrer le photographe et
son avocat et et il lui en proposer un
million de francs pour que parce que il
y avait quand même à l'époque poivre
d'arvor était encore mais ça
c'est une autre histoire c'est pour dire
que toutes les affaires de tf1 poivre
d'avor été mises en avait été mis en
examen dans la sphère besoins et avait
été déjà condamné en première instance
il avait été condamné en appel cette en
cassation dont il est toujours présumé
innocent tant mieux pour lui il fallait
pas ajouter des
chaussures sur faire ressortir des
choses sur tf1 donc on a essayé
d'acheter le photographe pour un million
de francs et manque de bol le
photographe avait un avocat maladroit
qui s'est dit puisque c'était fin et
qu'ils me proposent une brique on va en
demander 5 et ça s'est arrêté là
négociations ont capoté et du coup il ya
eu des procès du coup ça a été ça a été
jugés à créteil le bras avec des
condamnations qui ont d'ailleurs été des
condamnations assez
partagés puisque d'une part les
agresseurs du paparazzi ont été
condamnés pour violences et caetera et
lui le paparazzi il a été condamné pour
âge c'est plus atteinte à la vie privée
ou des choses puisque vous dites dans
votre bouquin surtout qui est
intéressant c'est que en fait le jour où
le monde le journal le monde publie
les résultats le verdict du tribunal en
l'apportant n'y a pas d' attaque quoi
tout le monde peut le raconter c'est pas
un problème quoi lorsque la formation
ces
informations
et évidemment il ya un commentaire qu'il
n'y a pas de commentaire là-dessus
unique photo mais c'est la sède c'est
uniquement de la formule 1 mais surtout
ce qui est amusant c'est que la première
fois quand ça sort dans le monde ce
n'est pas encore sorti dans voici voilà
ce qui est mystérieux et ça j'y
travaille encore moi et j'ai toujours
pas réussi à percer ce mystère pourquoi
y at il des grandes stars qui échappe à
pied chaque star voici ils sont qui
n'ont jamais de le guider alors qu'en
dehors de joindre des gens qui déjeunent
avec vous je pense que ça ça concerne
pas énormément nom de l'or ça fait très
peu de chances avec depardieu quand il
cependant moto ivre mort ça fait quatre
lignes dans le journal ça fait pas la
une qua non non non tout le monde et
c'est effectivement de baisser le feu au
maximum comme c'est comme ça pourquoi
relais
je sais pas il ya une les gens quand la
carte oui il ya une distribution de bons
points c'est ce que je dis c'est vrai
que samy naceri se fait serrer 1 rue
saint denis avec un petit peu de poudre
de couleur blanche tout le monde en
parle mais moi je connais des gens des
acteurs célèbres fils d'acteurs
eux-mêmes célèbres qui ont eu les mêmes
problèmes et qui sont sortis du comice
est un lien totalement blanchi
il faut dire ça pour conclure avec
puisque vous aviez apporté à voici en
dehors de la collaboration de gens comme
frédéric ou baissant au rouge ennahda
c'est vrai que vous avez apporté à voici
un ton d'humour kangoo qu'on voit bien
là c'est à dire que dans la façon dont
les légendes été rédigé les chapeaux les
titres enfin y avait une deuxième degré
ce qui rendait le journal à la fois
intéressant pour les peaux les braves
gens qu'il a achetée chez auchan et puis
aussi pour des gens un peu plus
sophistiquée oui ils étaient ils étaient
j'avais sud enfin je magasine tout
public et puis surtout d'enlever ce qui
met encore souvent reproché aujourd'hui
cette impression que le journal en
voulait à certaines personnes et en
voulait d'une façon génère halle aux
artistes alors que vous saisissez
simplement à raconter un peu là la phase
un peu caché des choses lui sont plus
vous êtes invités ou là
je réponds à qui on
avait juste fait inviter vous voulez
dire en promotion pour les savoir ce que
vous faites quand même normal les gens
vous j'ai fait plein de choses ce matin
j'ai fait des grosses têtes sa dernière
matin 1 j'ai fait les grosses têtes
et hier soir j'ai fait albert algoud et
je vais partir un petit peu en vacances
en écosse j'espère que je ne serai pas
suis pas je suis avec ma fille alors il
n'y aura pas un grand profit l'argent
est là que 11 ans justement
j'ai dit comment le livre commence et se
termine sur ce sur ceux ci à l'heure où
j'écris ces lignes j'apprends que xavier
couture et puggy rond chez grasset à la
et alors en fait il y avait deux
questions je voulais poser est ce que
vous apprenez ou non vous écrivez c'est
l'idée est ce que vous avez écrite parce
que vous avez appris qu'il va y avoir un
rebond c'était la première question est
le deuxième question c'est qu'est ce que
vous avez à lui dire puisque vous deux
tout à fait dit ce que vous pensez du
roman écoute et non je les ai y ajouter
parce que effectivement j'ai réussi
parle par des moyens tout à fait
illégaux comme ceux des soutiens souvent
dans son livre et par une turpitude
supplémentaires je me suis procuré
quelque chose qui circule dans toutes
les maisons d'édition c'est à dire les
épreuves non corrigées et j'ai donc pu
lire des choses qui ont un petit peu
géré venait d'angleterre d'ailleurs qui
ont un peu gâché ma traversée parce que
c'est j'ai fait un effort quand même
pour lire ce livre est ce que je peux
lui dire moi je le résume vrai en une
chose après tout qu'il raconte une
histoire totalement abracadabrante avec
des personnages qui ne tiennent pas
debout on peut lui pardonner après tout
il est par mancier cela dit ils auraient
pu encore attendre quatre ans puisque
cervantès a commencé à écrire à 54
peut-être qu'il a commencé un peu trop
tôt ce que je pourrais lui dire c'est
que moi j'ai écrit un livre où j'ai
essayé de mettre les choses de plus à
plat possible parce que je trouvais que
c'était intéressant de dégonfler des
baudruches et surtout de 10 de d'enlever
toute cette espèce de menaces people qui
tournerait autour des gens et qui en
fait n'existe pas or lui dans son livre
il a réintégré sa je pense que si comme
il le laisse entendre souvent il a
vraiment souffert
et je comprends qu'il ait souffert parce
qu'un des articles plus déplaisant qu'il
ait pu lire c'est une lettre que sa
femme nous envoyait à titre tout à fait
gratuit et en plus quand on lui a
demandé nous envoie également des photos
de famille elle les a envoyés par
federal express parce qu'à l'époque elle
était aux états unis bon tout ça à la
certainement profondément touché je
pense que s'il avait raconté mois zavier
couture comment j'ai souffert je pense
que dans un récit plus sincère il aurait
fait un livre plus vrai plus touchant
alors que là c'est une pantalonnade
parce qu on enlève le rédacteur en chef
dans des conditions totalement
incroyable et en plus pour insonoriser
la pièce on met de la laine de verre or
la laine de verre est un isolant
thermique et
c'est très important je viens quand on
écrit faut pas faire n'importe quoi
comme balzac veut faire de la chronique
il se renseigne avant donc je pense que
l'erreur de monsieur couture c'est de
s'être un peu laissé emporter par sa
part sa colère son mécontentement et du
coup je moi je trouve que c'est ce que
je sais pas ce qu'il ya écrit le
frédéric là dessus mais enfin pour moi
c'est une blague quoi c'est une petite
intrigue qu'on aurait torché à 17 ans et
demi bien écouter merci jacques collin
quant à xavier couture bat xavier si tu
nous regardes tu es le bienvenu pour
répondre à colin puis aussi pour nous
parler de ton bouquin voilà à très
bientôt merci ici après les pubs place
et notre coup de zoom sur son flanc le
nouveau spectacle des épis noirs au
théâtre de la gaîté montparnasse et
place en huitièmes le portrait du
cinéaste josé mojica marines à plus
chers amis chers ennemis trois fois on
se retrouve
on se retrouve avec vladimir de salut
ouais
ça va bien parce que je suis en train de
me rendre compte que la pub est saisie
d'une crise d'honnêteté alors chaix a
dressé
les saisines une vraie crise d'honnêteté
c'est à dire qu'elle nous assènent des
vérités dont on pouvait pas fin il ya
quelques années on n'aurait jamais cru
que nous dire des choses pareilles par
exemple elle nous démontre notre statut
d'esclave moi même je vais quand même
pour la publicité c'est pas c'est pas
courant j'en veux pour preuve un film de
pub qui passe actuellement sur les
écrans quai pour alors c'est un film
qu'il faut lire pour une voiture haut de
gamme qu'on appelle en publicité le
segment c ça y est le segment c c'est la
voiture pour le projet a reçu le chef
d'entreprise entre deux cent mille cinq
cent mille francs donc c'est des batchs
rcd voiture ou la vulgarité de
l'argument est complètement conscrites
c'est à dire qu'on ne doit pas dire si
elle freine bien si elle roule vite
scellé puissante si on dit simplement on
valorise le statut social de la personne
qui est essentielle acheté c'est à dire
qu'on va faire c'est un objet statutaire
c'est plus un moyen de transport c'est
simplement le reflet de la de la qualité
de la personne de l'aide de sa qualité
dans la hiérarchie sociale alors bon
c'est bien joli de flagorner comme ça
les chefs d'entreprise les câbles mais
au bout d'un moment on
on finit par passer précédent pour un
flagorneur et puis par part est ridicule
alors il ya une marque a réussi a
justement à renouveler ce discours du de
l'objet statutaire et alors c'est cette
marque c'est audi alors ils ont sorti un
film qui est assez surprenant je propose
qu'on regarde magnéto
dow jones gagnent leur corps
ne voulait pas comment des âges et
planck un beau diable
[Musique]
vous avez vu ce que nous montre ce film
d'horreur le cauchemar le cauchemar de
l'homme d'affaires ce qui a pour
interlocuteur quoi des clients des
clients qui sont pendus à leur portable
qui n'est ni bonjour ni au revoir dit
merci qui ont perdu leur portable qui
passent des ordres en bourse à 2
millions de dollars qui s'autoproclament
forking géniaux et le type doit toute la
journée supporter des gars comme ça en
plus toute la journée et toute la soirée
c'est à dire que le premier film qui
nous montre que le chef d'entreprise ne
connaît pas les 35 heures puisqu'il
travaille vidéo puis sacerdoce jean marc
roberts
exactement il obligé de se taper des
pinces fesses lamentable des restaurants
où on attend trop longtemps etc et tout
ça pour se coltiner les types qui qui
qui l'humilie finalement parce que
qu'est ce qu'on voit dans ce type était
humilié il est ignoré par son client il
et il va passer ensemble ils étrennent
oui clientèle lui est due et rai odile
clients très mercedes erra donc là le
gars on sent on a l'impression qu'il va
péter les plombs et même il ya même un
petit malentendu presque on a
l'impression qu'il est là qu'il est le
lan ployer de son clan drilles kylie
kylie son esclave finalement et qu'est
ce que nous dit la pub mais vous n'allez
pas vous plaindre vous allez pas vous
plaindre parce que vous avez une belle
bagnole vous pouvez être l'esclave vous
pouvez de l'esclave de la consommation
de ce que vous voulez mais vous n'allez
pas vous plaît parce que vous êtes vous
êtes riche vous avez les moyens de vous
payer une belle bagnole donc on va on va
pas vous plaindre et est ce qu'on ne dit
pas c'est que cette voiture a été payé
par abus de bien social
c'est une voiture de fonction on ne vit
pas
de nous dépeindre à ce point avec vous
dire que c'est la rédemption par la
consommation c'est à dire que vous avez
une vie de merde mais comme vous
consommez la bonne bagnols comme vous
avez acheté la bonne bagnole on va pas
vous peines et c'est cette consommation
qui va vous sauver du cauchemar qui que
normalement vous devriez être en train
de vivre alors c'est assez c'est quand
même c'est nouveau c'est nouveau que la
pub se permettent de nous dire un truc
surtout quand on va essayer de taper des
gens qui vont quand même débourser il
faut le dire deux cent mille à cinq cent
mille français il faut quand même
arriver à les convaincre paul tracy
c'est assez gonflé et ben je sais pas
bien
oui 14 14 14 oui c'est un titre d'agent
ce qui vous plaît bien ouais surtout un
mec que des stagiaires chez moi il ya 20
ans et qui a fait fortune mais
retransmis chez dans l'autre l'autre
bras vie à vivre à vie mais ils ont du
talent sinon il faut dire qu'ils font
des trucs graphique ci dessus
mais j'aurai conclure cette histoire
d'esclaves parce que c'est quand même
important que la pub arrive aujourd'hui
nous dire que nous sommes des esclaves
de la pub elle même il ya un bouquin qui
cliquaient ce qui vient de sortir qui
est écrit par un type qui est en même
temps publicitaire et en même temps
fille d'honneur ce qui est quand même
parce que quand même pas courant il a
écrit un bouquin qui s'appelle vous
faites ça mieux que moi à cheval est
vivant c'est dominique quessada donc il
ay là il a écrit l'esclave mais très
juste en un mot je donnais une phrase de
ce bouquin la publicité termine le
travail laissé en souffrance par la
philosophie là où platon et ses
successeurs ont échoué à gouverner la
cité la publicité reprend les idéaux
d'une gestion rationnelle du troupeau
humain pour les marques et dans la chair
vive du monde moderne avec le fer rouge
d'un appareil de pouvoir planétaire
elles constituent ainsi à tous les sens
du mot l'achèvement de la philosophie
alors donc c'est un peu ça va exactement
dans le même sens que c'est moins drôle
que beigbeder je dis tout de suite c'est
moins drôle ça s'est un peu férus il
faut être un petit peu féru de
philosophie il est même impossible qu'on
avait
des choses à dire sur les rapports entre
philosophie et publicités qui sont pas
idiots voilà merci vous voulez des
meilleurs bientôt voilà on poursuit
notre coup de zoom sur flonflons le
nouveau spectacle des épis noirs au
théâtre de la gaîté montparnasse
remarquer lors des derniers molières
cette comédie musicale revisite la
génèse en chantant l'éden campagnarde un
dieu proxénète et bisexuels si pierrick
béquet est monté au ciel
[Musique]
tous les soirs à la gaîté montparnasse
ça déménage avec chant font une comédie
musicale drôle et décalé qui nous
raconte en moins d'une heure trente
l'histoire de l'humanité une histoire
forcément revu et corrigé
à la véritable représentation de
l'histoire de l'humanité
[Musique]
j'aimerais que nous commencions tout de
suite parce que c'est long
repérez l'été dernier au festival off
d'avignon la troupe franco suisse les
épis noirs aime mélanger les genres
swing manouche rockabilly funk et humour
à la buster keaton font bon ménage
c'est très très énergiques ce qu'on fait
ton faut qu' une sorte de tourbillon sur
scène
[Musique]
des fatigues et juste avant des fatigues
et juste après puis pendant sais pas ce
qui se passe ça pète dans tous les coins
c'est comme le jeu d'acteur c'est comme
jouer comme des enfants qu'on aime bien
s'amuser à trouver plein de choses
nouvelles je m'arrêtais cette révolte
cuire les religions l'argent et le
calcul montage
x
je vais vous dire les guerres
michel dupin se multiplièrent les hommes
se soustraire les avait divisés pour
mieux
[Musique]
dans cette histoire là une fille et deux
garçons ça fait trois possibilités
[Musique]
pas de tabou tout est ultra deep
difficulté c'était d'y arriver tous les
soirs à être être le plus juste possible
donner le plus de bonheur possible à
faire partager ce bonheur avec les avec
le public
et
et envoyer de finale
merci et bravo tout simplement pierrick
béquet à l'occasion de l'hommage que
vient de lui rendre le festival du film
sud-américain de toulouse on enchaîne
ils doivent montrer qu'ils étaient sans
qu'il aimait lui ce sera à vous après du
cinéaste josé mojica marines le maître
du suspense érotico fantastique aux
cariocas yves montmayeur est allé danser
la samba magnéto
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce sorcier brésilien de 72 ans à dessus
défrayé la chronique à la fin des années
60 avec des films aussi fauché
qu'inspiré gore de grand guignol
perversion sexuelle matinée de rites
magiques blasphème religieux tout est là
pour hisser en effet notre josé au rang
des metteurs en scène les plus allumés
du septième art excommunié par l'église
censuré par l'état c'est égal deadwood
et de bela lugosi n'a cependant rien
perdu de son fluide charismatique
[Musique]
opprimés ring parc de cultiver au
vietnam au talon au cinéma et au visuel
soleil
[Applaudissements]
au bas mot
[Rires]
mariotti vie personnelle vie où ma
personne mais les magritte à only thing
au mur tout
les éléments tout ce qui est la radio
flash qui ont la balle jeudi makuma la
ferraille sur mac apple
et aux bourses et
des cachalots alias fringe aux
fossoyeurs pervers et assassin a
immortalisé marines au brésil qui a
interprété lui même le rôle vêtu allaman
drac éructant façon screamin jay hawkins
[Musique]
de la
paf avant
[Musique]
josé mojica marines fait aujourd'hui
partie intégrante du folklore brésilien
contemporain mais faisait t-il rire les
gens cette époque
certaines sur terre
à deux ou
dix avouent aux spiritueux incarne à 12
[Applaudissements]
génial non meilleur canadien voilà un
garçon qui sait ce que le cinéma c'est
intérieur gêne tout servir brest voilà
c'est ça
je vais continuer de me ronger les
ongles
bien maintenant mesdames et messieurs le
moment que vous attendiez tous oui voici
philippe et jean philippe je vais vous
dire j'avais vingt minutes
et tu appartiens au diable et adios
appartient les idéaux djabou que tu
laisses plie de thé sauce orange
6 je vais vous poser quelques de vide
est intelligent quelle est la région de
france où on en reste à table plus
longtemps parce qu'on aime ça le
sud-ouest très bien quel est le fil son
plaisir quel est le film préféré des
français depuis des plombes à droite la
boum non oui la vache et le prisonnier
il ya combien de pacs par mois 3000 ça
on devrait le savoir 1 200 mille milles
et il y en a eu 30 minutes la première
année dernière question combien de gens
se font-ils incinérés 20 % 10 % 7 %
c'est en augmentation permanente 39 pour
ça c'est beaucoup du don contre 48
seulement qu'ils se font enterrer
le monde sur le monde je suis fier je
n'ai plus que 16 minutes déjà lorsqu'à
de plus amusant c'est que là les raisons
pour lesquelles les gens se font
incinérer il ya une raison que ce soit
absolument sublime
la plupart france la plupart sont
incinérés pour des raisons écologiques
ou des choses comme ça mais il y en a 22
% qu'il soit considéré parce qu'ils
pensent que c'est une forme de liberté
sous ça va les aider alors où est ce que
je prends tout ce qu'on croit rien al
manar
pas banal mana c'est idiot mais pas du
tout non c'est un
ca du livre qui s'appelle dit et par les
éditions autrement bien sûr est toujours
de très bonnes choses si sa peine atlas
des français voilà et c'est la nasa
français c'est une espèce de petit de
petit traité de sociologie illustre est
illustrée par des graphiques des
statistiques et des écarts
des guerres
séduit
alors c'est un traité sur l'état de la
france sur l'état des moeurs des
habitudes des français les conditions de
vie etc
si ces signes et de madame laurence
dubois freiné et s'est appuyé sur les
réflexions et les travaux de
l'observatoire français des conjonctures
économiques est une chose très sérieuse
mais et travaux finis
les admirals à la france rabut les
travaux dirigés par le sociologue
l'ennui madras alors ça va tu es comme
jacques dion l'a vu de la vague de
l'internet au sec ça vient d'un rapport
au corps avec les habitudes religieuses
ça va de l'immigration votée à c'est un
vrai petit trésor et mais c'est sa sas
est assortie évidemment de réflexion
d'analysé sociologique ça dessine une
évolution profonde de la france celle
qu'avait justement analysé il ya une
quinzaine de cas cette année un jeu
passe le sociologue henri mendras
lorsqu'il avait
identifié cette évolution à une
révolution à la sq il avait appelé la
seconde révolution du mois de mai
certainement de rex madras dollars sur
le dernier
trimestre ils avaient identifié cette
évolution a une à une seconde révolution
française c'est d'autres qui l'avait
date est assez précisément dans les
années 1965 de révolution
encore un truc classique à chaque fois
vous parlait il ya un sourire dès les
années
il a plus que 12 mineurs pour madras et
pommades rasées dans les années 60 65 et
c'est ça l'idée très intéressante et
c'est très peinée france très brillant
non mais attendez écouter alors que les
stocks peuvent avoir le crawl que les
structures sociales issues de 1789 ont
disparu et que pareil vous entendez bien
paradoxalement les idéaux de 1789 ont
pénétré dans la société c'est à dire que
il a fallu deux siècles avant que les
véritables principes fondateurs de la
révolution entre dans la réalité sociale
c'est pas si pétain essentiellement la
légalisation des l'égalité des
conditions et la prééminence de
l'individu excusez moi je vous demande
de m'excuser parce que franchement si
c'est ce que vous êtes essayer de
communiquer téléspectateurs
fait chez moi même eu un peu moins de
tendresse
rien de plus intelligent
par exemple c'est vraiment plus je
préfère la raison coeur
de la ville en syrie non mais dans ce
cas là je vous condamne je reviendrai là
dessus car les réflexions de madras qui
publie dans un livre à qui est le
complément de cet atlas elles sont
vraiment très intéressante certaines
sont contestables mais je trouve qu'on
pourrait quand même de temps en temps ça
se être sérieux et nous devrions nous
intéressait sur l'état psychologique et
sociale et un mineur delà de la france
d'aujourd'hui je suis surtout à la
veille d'élections que sur capital pour
notre destin vous laissez pas tenter de
capitaliser
des hommes politiques à la télé pour en
parler alors je sais que le premier on
est premier on y reviendra et volontiers
une drague pas mais et vous avez tenu
l'atlas des français si vous voulez vous
distraire intelligemment formidable
voilà
voilà bah écoute et voilà on est un
petit peu désolé mais c'est fini c'est
fini pour aujourd'hui jason lee chargé
de la culture invité exceptionnel je
pèse mes mots claude nougaro bunker
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou